cornwall's rugged skyline proudly
displays its industrial past
but what would cornish miners have made
of this
the green revolution dominating the
horizon today
as a g7 summit legacy the prime minister
has promised cornwall will become the
uk's
first region to be net zero
it is a bold ambition i met these
surfers who build
boards from sustainable materials and
plant trees
in cornish soil the g7 leaders are just
over there i think in their hotel aren't
they
uh at cabbage bay it sounds like you're
pretty skeptical that anything
decent is going to come out of that when
it comes to the climate well i mean
climate change science has been in for
50 years and nothing's changed
we all know what the data says we all
know that climate change is real
and what we need is big action and what
we normally get is a lot of waffle
this weekend the spotlight and the sun
is on cornwall's green projects
some work better than others this wave
scheme
failed to turn the tide of the climate
crisis
so it's being turned into a floating
wind farm the celtic sea which is off
cornwall
is is has excellent wind resources for
us to come here it was a combination of
environmental benefits and a willingness
and partnership with the local
authorities summer and the summits mean
cornwall's roads have never been busier
creating more nature reserves like this
one
is vital by restoring land like this
by more reforestation and improving
biodiversity the aim is for cornwall
to take 404 000 tons of carbon dioxide
out of its atmosphere once cornwall
provided most of the uk's
tin and copper can the county now
provide a blueprint
for a greener future